to a lot of people carrot cake means a  sweet delicious treat made with well  carrots  but in singapore because that's how busy  your towels are  huh  what  [Music]  carrot cake is based on the traditional  dish fried rice cakes which was brought  to singapore by immigrants  this style of carrot cake is a savory  dish made of rice flour and white radish  which is also known as white carrot  hence the name carrot cake  it was in singapore that the radish was  added making it the dish known and loved  by singaporeans singaporeans like this  man  today it is so popular that a stall can  be found in nearly every hawker center  around the city  [Music]  what separates his from other vendors is  that he is one of the last remaining  people to make it by hand  [Music]  okay  [Music]  you